the amino acid sequence of cytochrome c
was determined for five different
species of vertebrates the table below
shows the number of differences in the
sequences between each pair of species
so just to give us some context for what
we're talking about we're talking about
cytochrome c this is a protein you might
remember it when we studied the electron
transport chain you don't really have to
know that for this question but it's a
protein that's found in a lot of
different species and we're going to
compare the difference in in the
sequence of amino acids for that protein
in the different species so even though
you have a the same or similar protein
we call them all cytochrome c the
sequence might be slightly different
when you go from one species of
vertebrate to another and the way to
read this is in e for each of these rows
you could say all right this is say this
row is describes d poly lepis and we can
see the number of sequence differences
between d poly lepis and g gallus
there's 18 differences there's clearly
going to be zero differences between
that species and itself
all right now let's answer their
question using the data in the table
create a phylogenetic tree on the
template provided to reflect the
evolutionary relationships of the
organisms provide reasoning for the
placement on the tree of the species
that is least related to the others
so
looking at these differences it's it's
it's reasonable to say well the things
that have the fewest differences in the
sequence of cytochrome c well those are
probably most closely related and they
already gave us a tree here so whatever
goes here and here are probably pretty
closely related they shouldn't have too
many differences in the sequence of
cider in in the sequence of cytochrome c
and these two should be pretty similar
shouldn't have many differences
while this one
should have a good number of differences
from any of the other four so let's
first look at which ones have very
little difference and i'm just looking
i'm just scanning this chart here
looking for small numbers so you see
here there's only one amino acid
difference or one sequence well yeah one
amino acid difference between cytochrome
c and e ferrous and e africanus so i
would say that these are fairly closely
related they probably share
an ancestor not too far in the distant
past so let me write e ferris and e
africanus
so i'll do it here e
e
ferrous
and e
e
africanus
i do that there now where else do we see
some low numbers well i see this three
right over here
and so that's that's dealing that's the
the number of sequence differences or
the amino acid differences between g
gallus and a
for steri forstery however you pronounce
that so i would say those are probably
pretty closely related
and so let me write this here
g
gallus
and
a
for
steri and who have we not dealt with yet
well we haven't dealt with
we haven't dealt with
d
polylepis yet we've dealt with the other
four so i'll put that here
d poly
lepis and you can see when you compare d
poly lepis to any of the other ones you
see a pretty big difference d poly lepis
to e ferrous it's a 21 difference 18
difference with g gallus 17 difference
with a for steri and a 20
20 amino acid
amino acids are different in the
sequence for cytochrome c between
d polylepis and e africanus so this is
this has the most differences and they
say
they say provide reasoning for the
placement on the tree of the species
that is least related to the others
so i'll provide the reasoning
so
d
polylupus
is
is most
is least related i should say
is least
related
because
it
has
a
large
amino acid
amino acid
sequence
difference
from the other four
from
the
other
other four or you can say has the
largest maybe i'll write that has the
largest amino acid sequence difference
from the other four because even if you
were to compare e ferrous to g gallus e
ferrous to g gallus you still don't get
close to 20 while d polylepis is pretty
close to 20 difference with all of them
and so that makes sense that even these
four share a common ancestor that you
don't have to go as far back in time to
get to the common ancestors you do to
get to d the common ester common
ancestor with d polylepis all right
let's do part b now
so that was part a let me label that
that was part a now part b identify
whether morphological data or amino acid
sequence data are more likely to
accurately represent the true
evolutionary relationships among the
species and provide reasoning for your
answer so morphological data this is
looking at the the morphology of the
different the different species and you
could say like okay what's the shape of
their backbone or their different bones
or or the the shape of different element
parts of their their body while amino
acid sequence well you're looking at
well what are their pro how are their
proteins actually made up i personally
would go with the amino acid data
so
i
i believe
i
believe
i believe amino
acid
sequence
data
are
data's plural are more likely
are more likely
to accurately represent the true
evolutionary relationship are more ac
are more likely to
represent
the true evolutionary relationship
true evolutionary
relationship
and let me provide my reasoning
you could have convergent morphology
you
can have
convergent
morphology and that all that means is
for example you could look at a bat's
wings and a bird's wings and say okay
look they have similar morphology but
they aren't related just because they
they both have wings or you could look
at a dolphin and a fish and you say okay
they both have flippers uh maybe they're
more closely related if you just look at
the body type but that's convergent they
actually came from
different ancestors but then their
ancestors because they had similar
environments had con had convergent
parts i guess you could say had
convergent morphology you can have
convergent morphology
morphology
while having very well while being far
apart on the evolutionary tree
while
being
far
apart
on
evolutionary
evolutionary
tree
now there's arguments for morphology as
well because you might be looking at you
know we're only looking at cytochrome c
here
that might be some type of an anomaly or
maybe you have some convergence or
divergence for for that particular
protein that is does not actually gel
with what's actually actually happened
in evolutionary history but in general
if i can look at the the molecular
sequences if i can look at sequences of
proteins if i could look at what's going
on with the dna i i like looking at that
because that doesn't that allows you to
not be tricked by the convergent
morphology uh of far apart things like
bats and birds or dolphins and fish